here's a quick quiz on adult Vital Signs  what is a normal blood pressure in an  adult  the answer is anything less than 120  over 80. so you want that systolic which  is the top number to be anywhere between  90 to 120 millimeters of mercury and  that bottom number the diastolic to be  anywhere between 60 to 80 millimeters of  mercury what is a normal respiratory  rate  a normal rate is anywhere between 12 to  20 breaths per minute now what is a  normal heart rate  the answer is 60 to 100 beats per minute  what is a normal spo2  it is anything greater than 95 and then  lastly what is a normal body temperature  the answer is 97 to 99 degrees  Fahrenheit  98.6 degrees Fahrenheit is the average  body temperature in an adult